what's going on guys this is Rob and
today I want to have a discussion about
magneto but I don't really want to have
a discussion about him in terms of his
abilities and whatnot I feel like that's
been done to death I want to have a
discussion about magneto as far as who
he is as an individual and his
philosophical viewpoints magneto is the
perfect example of a man chasing his own
shadow or a dog chasing its tail I think
is a better better example magneto is he
is a perfect example of a man who has
allowed his personal experiences to
dictate his life rather than allowing
them to influence his life and here's
what I mean by that a lot of us or I
don't know if I'd really give it a
particular number I would say that some
of us have grown up in households where
we have experienced nothing but good
times great memories and family
get-togethers and great Christmases and
Thanksgivings and we have experiences in
life after that that are sometimes
negative and sometimes reinforce our
positive views of humanity for some of
us it's the opposite some of us have
been raised in households and we've
known nothing but bad times and we've
experienced good things in life and
we've experienced bad things that
reinforce our negative viewpoint of
society but what we do is we take these
experiences and we allow them to
influence our lives we walk through the
world knowing that not everyone's going
to be nice but not everyone's going to
be terrible you simply have to take
people as they are with Magneto it's not
like that
Magneto of course was raised during the
era of the Holocaust of World War two
and he has allowed both this experience
and future events that have taken place
throughout humanity itself and the
involvement of humanity in terms of
their oppression of mutants to dictate
his viewpoints of humanity and so he has
this very cynical view his idea is that
the only way mutants will be free is if
they are freed from humanity and that
can only be done in one of two ways
either Humanity is eradicated entirely
or humanity is forced into a position of
subservience to mutants and we see and
we actually see that play out we see
that play out in the house of
in storyline albeit for a very short
time when the skull at which alters
reality and mutants are now the ruling
class and humans are subjugates and of
course at the pinnacle of it all is the
House of M or the house of magneto
what's really kind of intriguing here is
that despite the fact that Magneto's
past experiences have led him to believe
that humans are inherently a threat to
humanity
his very actions and the events that he
the events that he engages himself in
reinforced this viewpoint in humanity
because of the fact that magneto
constantly engages in acts that
effectively try to spark a war between
humans and mutants he does nothing more
than increased the rift that currently
exists between humans and mutants and
this really seems to be something that
he doesn't recognize or something that
he refuses to recognize now the question
that I would pose here is are his views
justified is he justified in saying that
humanity will inevitably come to a point
where they will wage war against mutants
and either mutants have to be prepared
for it or a mutant simply have to nip
that in the bud and force humanity into
subservience there have been several
instances in the Marvel Comics universe
where we've seen different scenarios
play out but based on these ideologies
we've seen scenarios like the Days of
Future past or bishops timeline where
humans became the sort of mainstream
oppressor to humanity - I'm sorry means
became a sort of sort of subject gets to
mutant to humankind that is to say
humans sort of imposed their will on
mutants and enslaved them for the most
part we've seen instances like the Age
of Apocalypse or the House of M where
mutants are ruling over humanity and
humanity kind of exists in a state of
subjugation and a state of fear we've
seen instances again from bishops Tom
line where during the summers rebellion
humanity and mutants band together to
fight a single cost the single cause
being to cast off the signal oppression
of the world as a whole we see these
different instances play out but when
you're kind of looking at
the world through Magneto's eyes he's a
very intelligent human being I guess a
very intelligent mutant and so when he
looks at humanity overall that is to say
from the time the humanity first waged
war against itself all the way to the
present day you've seen nothing but
instances where an advanced class has
ruled a less advanced class and this is
kind of the same viewpoint of all of our
Trask had in the last view the last
video that we discussed all of our Trask
had this viewpoint that when a more
advanced society meets a less advanced
society the more advanced society will
oppress and conquer the less advanced
society Magneto kind of sees mutant kind
as being the more advanced the next step
in evolution and so in addition to his
viewpoints of humanity is attempting to
oppress mutant kind we must stop this he
also views beaten kind in an arrogant
way that is to say mutants are better
than humans therefore mutants should
rule humans humans were meant to be
ruled and this I think is really kind of
the core of his belief system it's
really kind of the focal point you know
I think his views on humanity and and
the oppressive nature of humanity and so
forth kind of spin around and I think
that his his views in terms of his life
life experiences kind of spin around but
when you're talking about someone as
powerful and charismatic as Magneto I
think that the the core belief the the
eye of the storm so to speak is this
idea that mutants for the next step and
it makes no sense for mutants to be
oppressed or to be anything less than
the ruling class and society overall but
in the end I think that magneto has
really demonstrated himself to be a very
popular character and in fact I think
he's ranked number one across the board
for the most part with regards to his
popularity among fans I mean he was the
first Vil in the x-men font and he's
been in the comics ever since he really
hasn't gone away he's disappeared for
time he's come back his ORN you know
kind of come back at somebody else but
he's always been in the background he's
always been the hidden hand behind a lot
of different things but uh but yeah so
we're gonna go and bring this video to
an Ana hope you guys enjoyed it if you
did let me know and I will catch you
guys later peace